whether you're buying gifts or stocking
up for entertaining many of us are
getting an early start on holiday
shopping this year lifestyle expert amy
soul is here with some ideas to help us
get ready for the season
i'm amy sewell this is the week when
most of us get serious about holiday
shopping and if you're looking for ideas
for gifts and entertaining i worked with
several companies to put together some
ideas now we all love our pets and there
are so many tasty treats out there for
the pets in your life dreambone is known
for their rawhide free easy to digest
chews and your dog will feel right at
home at the holiday dinner with these
treats that are made with real chicken
but they're shaped like holiday hams
smartphones also has healthy
alternatives to rawhide like these
holiday canes that are made with real
chicken and wholesome vegetables both
smart bones and dream bone also have
these chews in cute holiday shapes like
snowmen gingerbread men and christmas
trees these are a delicious diversion
that let pets indulge their natural
chewing instincts on nutritious chews
instead of on your holiday decorations
good and fun also has a savory
smorgasbord of flavors like these triple
flavored treats made with real beef hide
pork hide and chicken the santa variety
pack and the holiday variety jar include
assortments like kabobs twists and
chicken flavored crunchy sticks for even
more fun this crunchy ribs plus jar
includes a naughty or nice squeaker or
you can count down the 12 days of
christmas with their holiday calendar
now not only will your furry best
friends love these delicious long
lasting shoes but these will look
adorable in the holiday photos dreambone
and smartphones are easy to find on
amazon and you can find these good and
fun gifts at walmart
of course we all want to look our best
for holiday parties and photos people
are going for more glamorous eye makeup
looks this season but if your eyes are
red from late nights or lack of sleep no
amount of mascara or eyeliner will cover
that the secret to reducing redness and
helping eyes look brighter is lumify
redness reliever eye drops from bausch
and loam just one drop in each eye
significantly reduces redness to help
your eyes shine and look more beautiful
when used as directed you can use lumify
drops even if you wear contacts you just
need to wait 10 minutes after applying
them before inserting your lenses these
are easy to find in the eye care aisle
at retailers and they're an affordable
stocking stuffer for beauty lovers you
can find more information at
lumifydrops.com
now to get more sleep any time of year
this hatchery store smart sleep
assistant from bed bath and beyond uses
a combination of soothing sounds smart
light and meditation to help you
personalize the sleep weight routine
it's sunrise alarm gently wakes you with
light instead of sound and it's easy to
operate either through touch or a nap
you can find this at bedbathbeyond.com
[Music]
for a sweet treat to share with family
and friends this seasonal holiday
collection from e creamery includes four
pints of their hand-packed holiday ice
creams in flavors such as peppermint
bliss made with red velvet cake and
creamy peppermint icing and my personal
favorite snickerdoodle cookie in
addition to their holiday collections e
creamery has packages that allow you to
select your own flavors and create
custom labels the ice cream is packed
and shipped in dry ice so everything
arrives in great condition this
collection is 59.99 plus shipping at
ecreamery.com
finally you can bring holiday cheer to
everyone with nothing bundt cakes and
make it your one-stop shop for all of
your celebrating needs they're
handcrafted delicious full-size bundt
cakes individually wrapped gauntlets and
bite-sized buntinis are perfect for
gifts or entertaining decorated cakes
like this pumpkin spice give thanks cake
make fabulous hostess gifts or double as
a festive centerpiece
buntinis with fall leaves or ugly
sweater toppers make cute place settings
and botlet towers in flavors like red
velvet or lemon make tasty stocking
stuffers
you can order online or at one of their
400 plus bakeries nationwide you can
find your local bakery and ordering
information at nothingbundtcakes.com
for more information check out
shopwithstyle.com happy holidays
thank you to shop with style and their
partners which you can see on your
screen for sponsoring this segment for
more information check out
shopwithstyle.com
[Music]